well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
in the next half hour then we will see
what's making the headlines
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
maria kevin mcguire hello hello
great to see you both um they said i'm
wearing a tie
i know we did notice you look smart
good i'd say kevin it's a novelty
was he acquitted
oh yeah well why else would he wear a
tie oh
yeah show you up maguire to show you up
for being the scruff you are
shall i get to the front page of me
better had don't you anyway right so the
telegraph then oh the ft apologies
describes the government's vaccination
targets as being
in peril after nhs england revealed the
uk will face
a significant reduction in vaccine
supplies
from the 29th of march for at least four
weeks
telegraph predicting the development
will paralyze the rollout
the weight faced by the under 50s is
also the big story for the guardian
surprise slump in vaccine supplies is
the splash in the eye
the metro reporting that despite several
of its member states refusing to use
them
the eu intends to retain millions of
doses
of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine which
could have been shipped to
the uk while the daily mail leads with
plans by the
home secretary to reject asylum seekers
who arrive from countries deemed safe
and the arrest of a 50 year old man and
the questioning of tv personality
michael barrymore
in connection with the death of stuart
lubbock 20 years ago
makes the front of the mirror so andrew
kevin are here
this letter warning about a dip in
vaccine supplies clearly dominating the
newspapers
despite matt hancock suggesting the road
is bumpy in terms of supplies
um how serious should we take this then
telegraph
first of all then kevin yeah what's the
first big hiccup with what's been
incredibly successful at nhs mascot
program
and matt hancock called that press
briefing today really not to announce
anything new he just wanted to take a
bow and
give himself a big pat on the back that
we've now exceeded 25 million doses and
the letter coming out
rather rained on his parade the
telegraph very pro-government uh paper
they are talking about uh
it'll paralyze the roll out no birth
bookings for first jobs no no no fresh
boogies for first jobs are going to be
taken in april the
telegraph says the shortage uh what
called lumpy
supply uh in hancock's book words is uh
is linked to a delay in five to ten
million doses of the oxford astrozonica
uh vaccine from india um
so it is a it is a problem um the
government says it will still hit its
target of all over 50s by the middle of
next month
all adults by the end of july and that's
good and where
in advance of most other countries in
the
in the world but it did just show the
unpredictability as the government um
does pat itself on the back uh and in
some ways yeah
it's right it got the nhs to do this had
the foresight to go after vaccines at
the beginning
and got just about everything else wrong
in corolla virus but but this
end has been uh correct doesn't doesn't
undo 125 000 plus deaths and so on
but um now it just shows it is
unpredictable and i think they should
cease being so celebratory uh because
unfortunately it can yes and always been
i mean sort of secretive about
the supply chain where it's coming i
mean remember scotland published
details and sort of got reprimanded for
it and so on and in the middle of the
picture
in the telegraph is ursula von der lion
the eu commission president
who's effectively said today why are we
shipping vaccines to you
if you don't ship some back it doesn't
hurt
i suppose the uk's case for keeping its
vaccines
if the eu hear that we have a shortage
for a month does it
no it doesn't but um ursula von der lyon
is a complete idiot
there's no other word for this woman the
european union has
62 million we've sent 62 million
vaccines of astrazeneca to the european
union and they've used 48 million
so there are 14 million in various
bridges across the european union
and currently 18 countries within the
european union
have have paused they use the word pause
rather than suspended
using the astrazeneca vaccine because of
unsubstantiated scare stories
started by that full president macron
who said people over 65
shouldn't use it when challenged about
the scientific evidence for it said
oh actually there isn't any and then
germany went down the same route so
quite why she is now threatening um a
massive
ratcheting up of the war of words
between britain and the european union
when she's got member states crying out
in fear and loathing and agony because
they haven't got enough vaccines
because of her failure to procure enough
in the first place
she put her order in for astrazeneca
vaccines three months after ours
she didn't put in enough orders and she
was also hammering astrazeneca
on the price now this is just a silly
distraction from her
what really is important for us is there
is potentially now
a shortage coming down the line we are
relying on india to supply some of the
astrazeneca ones
also there are plants in belgium germany
uh
and one other country in europe uh so um
and and let's hope hank hancock's right
it is just lumpy
production but why this is a big story
it's because it was
so unexpected in my view that's why it's
on so many front pages we didn't see
this coming
there was no hint there was no pre-spin
which is what you often get with
ministers they try and massage
opinion this came completely out the
blue yes and in fact um just on europe
um interestingly some nations are now
looking to
to russia's vaccine aren't they the
sputnik v which has all sort of
geopolitical implications itself you
know nations like hungary for example
um but back to the uk the deadline has
always been
mid-april to do the first one to nine
cohorts well they're easily on track for
that
even with this blip aren't they so
perhaps it was all just
factored in i mean you know the the nhs
letter seemed much more in
being concerned than matt hancock's tone
today
yeah you know what we've seen the daily
vaccination figures out i think
they varied from just over 200 000 to
half a million so you can see there that
the flow of the vaccine which is a
it's a culture it has to be grown it's
not like getting
cars off the bmw line
it's it's rather more complex than that
where the government
it's kept constantly saying we're doing
better than we expected better than we
expected
and this is the first hiccup i think the
answer to your question is i think
diplomatically
it does help uh in that uh our
biology with the the european commission
but
it's it's kind of um it's almost as if
some of the european
uh union countries or the european union
countries can't make their mind because
some are suspending the use of the
astrocytic uh uh
vaccine and then the european commission
wants more of it
and is jonathan vantam the deputy chief
medical officer in england who i think
is the best communicator they have as he
said well there's no point having this
vaccine sitting in fridges it's got to
be in your arms to
protect you so i think i think it does
help uh
internationally that there is this
little problem but at home
it does mean those under 50s i mean i
think i think
andrew's had his uh had his vaccine
because of his very
advanced age uh you must become
uh for yours uh i've i've had mine too
but those are
mine today actually and i have to say it
was you know it was um
so well organized it made me quite teary
about what sort of scientific miracles
it is
that there is such a thing that can get
us get us out of this pickle that we're
all in and it feels like a just a really
long road for everyone to get there and
you know you hope i mean you know you
talk to people in in itu
in there they've got people in their 40s
which is why it's so important that that
age band also gets the vaccine
but many parts of london have been
giving it to people in their 40s
and in their 30s so maybe this nhs
letter is a way of saying
actually you really shouldn't be doing
that even if you're doing well who knows
anyway
well when you get different areas going
at different speeds and some yeah some
are more
or people people are easier to contact
and get along because we know there are
some groups of
of people who are from various
backgrounds
not all um you know ethnic ethnic
minorities
but we have problems with some care
workers for instance uh which i
find very puzzling who will reluctant to
get it and some areas are just better at
contacting
for whatever reason getting people
coming along so they're going at all all
different sp
at different speeds i got mine pretty
pretty early in my
age group because very very effective uh
gp
um practice in a in an area that was for
speed and speed and
speeding ahead but um this is this is
the first hiccup we just got to hope it
is a hiccup but those under
under 51 they want to be protected for
health reasons but two some of them
would be looking forward to
life reopening and going on holiday
traveling abroad when they may need to
have
their job and that could be delayed now
yeah and you talk to some gps they say
if you then go back and do the
backtracking which we heard jonathan
vantam matt hancock today saying they
want to do
to get everybody to get this jab um only
about 10
still refuse to have it and everyone's
got a different reason why they don't
have it
and some of those can be persuaded so
that's what they i guess they do now
don't they um
metro just quickly we'll grab your jabs
we've already talked about ursula von de
line and europe really haven't we
um but let's talk about uh cummings
who's really thrown the boot in has he
not
to matt hancock and others uh calling
for an inquiry
etc smoking ruin on ppe and procurement
it was fascinating andrew yeah and
and how much we've missed him uh this is
a man who was a dominant figure in the
government until
he got the push by boris when was it
november december i can't remember when
he went
uh and he came back firing all pistons
there is definitely going to be an
inquiry anyway into covid there will
definitely be a
queries of what went wrong and he
illustrated
very much at the beginning he protected
the prime minister you noticed at
this stage but he will be called at some
later point to talk about number 10's
role and he put the boot in straight on
that hancock he said it wasn't fit for
purpose
look i don't think it's just fair to
blame matt hancock actually
over the failures over ppe for instance
we know that jeremy hunt who was our
longest serving health secretary
very good health sector in my view very
uh polish political performer
when he was selected to state the health
they had preparations for pandemic
planning
and um they were told that they didn't
have enough ppe then
and nothing was done about it so these
problems go back to
david cameron's government he's a maze
government and poor old man hancock
got numbered and then there was that
great panic when the
when the pandemic arrived and they were
buying uh people from all sorts of
inappropriate places including
matt hancock's governor of his local pub
for god's sake it's why
people like the daily mail stepped in to
organize great ppe runs from around the
world because there was a problem
but clearly there was a big problem but
what he said was really interesting
there was a deliberate decision to keep
the department of health out of order or
getting involved with
the vaccine because they've made such a
mess
of ppe and um you have to say if that
was
if that was true then it was the right
decision because as we've said earlier
the rollout of the vaccine has been
phenomenal up until now
kevin just really quickly because we
need to get to a break on
as saint jeremy of hunt has admitted
when he was health secretary he didn't
leave the nhs in a fit state to deal
with a crisis like this so that's not to
get too carried away about his
glorious ring now i watched cummings and
i actually thought
you know it just shows you the flawed
judgment of johnson and employing him
and giving him so much power
because he just brushes over cummings
over his
own failings that catastrophic loss of
public confidence on his eye test drive
to barnard castle
uh just being one of them others were
remember let's try and get herd immunity
he was pushing that he wasn't the only
one
he denies that though i think doesn't he
so you know subsequently he has done
that
yeah he denies aspects of it he denies
he was just going to let people die
that's what he that's what he that's a
bit he denies that he wasn't
going to kill loads of uh old people but
that would have been the impact of his
uh
program until he panicked well
i'm sure he i'm sure he's come out to
deny that but i mean it'd be really
interesting to sit down and properly
quiz him about
the last year wouldn't it that's i mean
they did a little bit of that in the
committee today
plenty more still to come including uh
misogynistic behavior
looks said to be made a crime we will
debate the merits of that after the
break
the crime part obviously well welcome
back you're watching the press preview
with me now andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire
um to historical uh claims of sexual
abuse in football now
a big report today this is uh in the
guardian isn't it kevin
yeah clive sheldon qc commissioned to
look into
decades of abuse and the premier league
and football association clubs are
apologizing for institutional failure i
mean they've been slow to act uh
since 1995 when uh there were
prosecutions convictions of the sports
two
and so many young people were still
preyed upon
absolutely absolutely appalling for
because these were
young in football you mainly then young
men who were wanting to succeed and so
they became
incredibly vulnerable to predators and
football's move now but has it has it
gone far enough yet
i mean we really won't be able to tell
uh for some time but you would you would
would hope it's in a much better
position now in the game that people can
can make complaints and actually it's
just like great get checks on on coaches
and people
who could be abusers and moving to
um a final story in the bottom of the
daily telegraph a small story today but
it continues the idea of
what you can do to protect women uh and
this is the idea that misogyny could be
included
as a crime kevin andrew rather
well it's this is as part of as a hate
crime it is extraordinary when you think
we've got
uh racism and homophobia uh they're all
they all can be regarded as hate crimes
how misogyny was excluded i don't know
particularly when you think
um how many women are now in the house
of commons did they try and get it
included i don't know
but the point about hate crime is i mean
my one worry about hate crime has always
been this
if you decide if you are for instance
an ethnic minority or a gay person if
somebody shouted something abusive at me
about my sexuality
i can then regard that as a hate crime
it has to be recorded as a hate crime
but it makes me very uneasy however
having said that
misogyny should be a hate crime because
if women are targeted because of their
gender their sex
we saw um that the great vigil on on
saturday which was disrupted by the
police what
shambles that was misogyny is important
and it's been
long long have men treated women as
third-rate citizens
we will see you both at half-eleven
thank you so far see you soon